al
is with us in dallas texas hi al what's
up
hello thanks for taking the call sure
what's up how can we help
so i actually got a letter saying that
we learned that the
county clerk's office office that
this capital recovery company has filed
a lawsuit against me
for unpaid debt and i do recall the debt
and it's actually a debt when we used to
be a single income family
and getting my wife through college and
all that
we did accumulate that debt and we
didn't pay it it was a credit card
and someone now is coming back to hunt
us after you know six seven years
and so this uh several law firms have
reached out to us and you know we can
help you with this
um and then we're trying to decide to
see if we just go ahead and
go directly with them and make an
arrangement they told me you know what
you could pay this whole thing off it's
going to cost you 4 500.
or you could go ahead and just set up
num sum of 3 000.
but then the lawyers then the lawyers
are reaching out to us and you know what
um you have nothing you know if you hire
us
we could go ahead and settle it for less
sometimes we could be able to go ahead
and eliminate it completely
and it's going to cost you 1200 bucks
yeah
probably bankruptcy lawyers calling you
and twelve hundred dollars is probably
for you to file bankruptcy
now the actual the twelve hundred
dollars uh the two hundred dollars is
for them to go ahead and take care of
the case
and and uh
they're gonna go ahead yeah but you said
they called you
right out yeah no i'm so sorry yeah
okay so what's the balance on the uh on
the credit card
the credit card is 4500. okay and
they've as
and the company has already off that is
suing he's already offered to settle
that for three thousand
he says you could pay us 4500 monthly
payments
no for the next 30 30 months not doing
that
but we could set a list for about three
three three thousand do you have any
money
what was that do you have any money do
you have any money
i could uh no where would you get any of
this money we're talking about
well i was thinking more of the
installment program to be part of the
of the data steps because we're on baby
step two
paying things off so now that this
what's your uh what's your household
income
um i mean take home like every month
it's like about six grand
okay after taxes between me and my wife
now
i would not hire an attorney to do a
settlement of this type
it's overkill and some of the attorneys
that are sending you letters are not
trying to work a settlement for you
they're going to file bankruptcy for you
and you've got to be real careful
there's a bunch of shysters in this
space
so um i don't think you need to what i
would do
is call the company back and say i can't
do three
but i can do two and i can do that
45 days from today because you can do
that if you stop your debt snowball and
you scrape up two during that 45 days
so i can do two but i can do two by
january the first
okay and if i let them know then uh
would have how would i
i would have to let them know how will
coming to that agreement as long as you
send me a letter saying you know we
read upon those two grand yep and then
you have to take the
the lawsuit against county because
that's what they did
but they they mentioned to me that that
they're going to be serving me papers
that's fine that's fine and so based on
serving them in papers i have to reply
to the county
and based on my elect when i let them
know it's not a big deal they can they
can you can
you can enter into an agreed order they
can do that themselves
if they agree to accept the 2000 uh just
tell them you need that to be an agreed
order
and they'll do it here's the thing let
me stop you a second okay the company
that's doing this this lawsuit
it feels to you like this is some kind
of drama lawsuit like you see on
television or something or like a court
case that involves criminal stuff
this is not like a lawsuit at that level
this is more like going to traffic court
for a ticket speeding ticket
is you know in other words these guys
when they filed this
they didn't file a single lawsuit
against you that day
they took boxes of lawsuits down there
and did them at one time
because they are a widget factory and
you are one widget
out of thousands of widgets that they're
going after
so this is much more it's very
transactional for them it's much more
like traffic court
than it is perry mason or matlock or
whoever right
csi or anything else right so
you know it feels you've never been sued
and it feels very
uh scary and the unknown of it feels
very dramatic
and very legal and i need a lawyer and
all of that if somebody was suing you
for 500 000
because of a car wreck and an injury
yeah get a lawyer
okay and there's times you need legal
representation i would not spend it
on this if i were you i would call them
and see if you can settle it for 2000
payment by the end of the year
and they need to enter an agreed order
with the county can you remember that
phrase agreed order
i agree i i i'm writing it down i agree
order with the county yeah and then they
need to send that to you in writing and
no
you they cannot have electronic access
to your checking account
and no you are not going to disclose a
bunch of financial information to them
including where you work or anything
else
yep and now you're going to need to take
a deep breath because you're going to
need to be on the ball with this
meaning writing it down i love that
you're taking notes but you're going to
write down who you spoke with the date
the time
the gist of the conversation like you
want to keep a full conversation log on
this
if you cannot get it to come to an
agreement
then you may want to spend 1200 and hire
an attorney to get them to come to
agreement for you
but make very very sure this is not
filing um a
bankruptcy the reason it comes up is i
was in texas the other day
and i'm driving down the road and
there's this big old yellow billboard
with these two guys and suits on it
and it says the the billboard is be
debt free and i thought oh that's some
local guys doing a
doing a talk radio show teaching people
how to get out of debt like inspired by
us or something i thought that's pretty
cool
and then i get to look at the billboard
as we're driving and it's bankruptcy
attorneys
but the ad doesn't say bankruptcy it's a
little bit at the bottom bankruptcy
attorneys
but the big thing is just two guys in a
suit saying be debt free and i thought
man somebody else has joined the crusade
that's awesome but no they didn't
no they were just lawyers yeah there's
money grabs and so um
that's exactly what that is what about
the people do this stuff
so yeah out just be very careful if you
do retain an attorney
the fact that they are soliciting you
and they're going through
the entire box of lawsuits and sending
them all letters and you're just one of
them right
and our fear is is that you end up with
a ten thousand dollar legal bill over a
three thousand dollar credit card yeah
so just be aware al thank you for
reaching out buddy
uh it took courage uh because you could
hear the fear in your voice
uh but you've got steps now to be able
to take uh to be able to protect
yourself
so three things you're gonna do get on
the phone with them come to an amount
around two thousand whatever you can
come up with by the end of the year
two thousand dollars by year end by 12
31 okay
if that's if you then second thing is
get that in writing
and uh when you do that agreement tell
them that that needs to be an agreed
order so they stop the lawsuit
until 12 31 after 12 31 they can come
after you if you don't pay it
but then um because you didn't follow
through on the agreed order
then the second step is it has all this
has to be in writing to
you and you keep that piece of paper the
rest of your life
and then the third thing is they do not
have electronic access to your checking
account and you do not give them any
financial information
when you pay them it'll be with pre
cashier's check or prepaid debit card
but no access to any of your other
accounts we don't want them to know
where they are
or that they exist so you're you're
putting up the shields
you really are because they're good they
will ask you questions in a way that you
don't feel interrogated where is it you
are
you feel like you're having a remains of
this conversation this conversation's
about two thousand dollars yes
it makes us go away i like all other
questions that don't have to do with
that are not gonna be answered not
dealing with it
this is two thousand dollars and i am
out of your life and you're out of my
life
and it's in writing and no electronic
access to my checking account it'll be
debit card or cashier's check those are
the three steps
greet order we're doing this boom and
i've done
tens of thousands of those and i am not
a lawyer
okay and i wasn't practicing law when i
did it i just simply negotiated on
behalf
of a client of ours a settlement
now you're allowed to do that for
yourself or literally for someone else
so um get her done dude i
i wouldn't pay the money unless you get
yourself painted into a corner and then
get a lawyer that's a real lawyer not a
bankruptcy attorney
protect yourself